hey guys tim ferriss here before we jump
into this episode I'm gonna do something
I very rarely do and that is to make a
direct ask with hat in hand my brand new
book just came out today it is called
tribe of mentors subtitle short life
advice from the best in the world
if you like the podcast you will love
this book I reached out to a hundred and
thirty people who are the best at what
they do in sports investing business
acting directing you name it we got it
cryptocurrency done and it turned out
better than I ever could have expected
many of my friends think of all my books
it is the easiest to read the easiest to
use so check it out please take a look I
put out so much free material the
podcast is free the 700-plus blog posts
are free every once in a while I put out
something like this and it's not that
expensive so please take a look
tribe of mentors dot-com and it does
make a great holiday gift or gift for
others there's something for everybody
in here it is really a
choose-your-own-adventure guide a buffet
of options for improving your life both
in business and in the personal sphere
so take a look I appreciate you taking a
look tribe of mentors calm or anywhere
that books are sold at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking can I ask
you a personal question
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by convertkit my go-to
email service provider a lot of you have
asked me what I use for email and I've
been hesitant to tell you because I
don't want to give them the hug of death
and have my own service drop so after
much consideration I finally said yes to
convertkit being a sponsor email is a
huge priority for me and I trust
convertkit as my ESP my email service
provider it's the only platform that I
can completely control and customize and
I need a service that ensures the right
information is sent to my followers and
listeners and I cannot afford downtime I
very little patience for it so I tried
all sorts of different platforms and
ultimately selected convertkit because
they deliver on what matters most to me
and my team easy to use systems split
testing super-important and resending
technology say - on opens high rates of
deliverability and excellent customer
service when I've needed something from
them when my team has needed something
from them they've always been there so
whether you run a business or just have
a professional blog let's say convertkit
offers email automation which allows you
to send well-timed targeted content to
your audience or your customers the
platform has all sorts of integrations
with more than 35 services including say
hosting sites such as WordPress
e-commerce platforms like Shopify lead
capture technology like bounce exchange
or sumo and many many more they offer
plans that can adjust to meet the size
of your business and they can scale with
you so convertkit can handle you whether
you have a thousand people or 1 million
people on your email list let's take a
look convert kit.com forward slash Tim
that's Co NV e RT ki t com forward slash
Tim and you can get your first month for
free that way you can test the platform
kick the tires make sure that it works
for you and your business and if you're
like me hopefully fingers crossed
because I only like to recommend things
that scale and do really well for
everybody I hope that you find they get
the job done that's certainly been the
case for me again that is convert
dot-com forward-slash Tim for a free
month of email services check it out
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for many many
years now travels with me on my
smartphone in my pocket at all times
I love audiobooks and they are one of my
favorite ways to make the most of the
time or just pass the time when I'm
taking walks cooking or on the road in
airplanes and so on audible has allowed
me to consume and enjoy many many more
books than I would have otherwise been
able to you can access an unbeatable
selection of bestsellers biographies
mysteries thrillers fantasy sci fi for
you nerds like me and much more so I can
recommend a few right off the bat ready
player one by Ernest Cline if you want
your sci-fi fix very very good stuff the
Tao of Seneca by Seneca if you want to
hear my favorite letters of all time
then that is one option and I have to
add one more perhaps my favorite
narration ever the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman the version read by Neil
himself ok as a listener of the Tim
Ferriss show as well
you can join audible for just 495 per
month that's $4.95 per month for your
first three months it's regularly 1495
so you save quite a bunch this offer is
available to new audible members only
and it ends December 31st 2017 go to
audible.com forward slash Tim that's
audible.com forward slash Tim or text
Tim T I am to five hundred five hundred
to get started now I wasn't sure what
that meant so I tried it out it's a
pretty cool technology actually if you
just text TI m to five zero zero five
zero zero as the phone number then it
delivers the URL and page directly to
you which is pretty cool I actually
might play around with that so you can't
make more time but you can make the most
of its check it out
audible.com forward slash Tim or text
the word Tim lowercase T I am to five
hundred five hundred to check it out and
get started now
hello my lovelies
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tribe of mentors
podcast which is likely also being
cross-post
on the Tim Ferriss show podcast this
episode is going to cover rejection or
more specifically rejecting other people
saying no many of the questions that I
get are about how to parse the noise
from the signal how to separate out the
trivial many say no to obligations and
fear of missing out so you can say yes
to the critical few this is an ongoing
challenge for a lot of people and the
tools and strategies and tactics the
help can almost overnight make an
enormous impact in different areas of
your life and you have various
guidelines that guests I've interviewed
for instance that Tim Ferriss show have
shared such as Derek Siver's who is not
only a very very accomplished
entrepreneur who built and sold CD Baby
also a musician and philosopher king of
programming in some respects would use
the hell yes or no heuristic in other
words if he doesn't say or can't say
hell yes I want to do that to something
the answer is a no it is binary and
there are many many other guidelines
like that that you might use but when
the rubber hits the road you need
specific words you need specific phrases
that you can use to decline and say no
and as it turns out when I was writing
the tribe of mentors book the tribe of
mentors short life advice from the best
in the world which ended up including a
hundred and thirty of the most
incredible world-class performers from
around the world in every discipline
imaginable many people I reached out to
said no I was rejected I was declined I
was mostly polite declined and it turned
out that some of those rejection letters
were so good they were so expertly
crafted that I turned right around and I
asked the people who rejected me if I
could include their letters in tribe of
mentors the book itself so I thought
what might be fun
is to read not just fun but practical
the three rejection letters that come to
mind right off the bat and these are in
little side featurettes I suppose called
how to say no in Drive of interest which
you should check out please I don't sell
much podcast and the blog posts all
700-plus of them are for free but tribum
interest calm Thanks
okay back to our regularly scheduled
programming so the first rejection
letter is from Wendy MacNaughton
very very impressive gal McNaughton is
spelled MACNA ugh t o n you can say
hello to her on twitter and instagram at
Wendy Mac M AC or you can see her work
and life and much more at Wendy McDon
calm all right here is Wendy Wendy
MacNaughton is a New York Times
bestselling illustrator and graphic
journalist based in San Francisco her
books include many many many many many
books I will just read a few of them
first
meanwhile in San Francisco comma the
city in its own words lost cat a true
love story desperation and GPS
technology pen and ink subtitle tattoos
and the stories behind them and we go on
and on and on
she's really prolific to the newly
released leave me alone with the recipes
wendy is also the back page columnist
for California Sunday magazine and
co-founder of women who draw now some of
you who have been tracking perhaps not
just this podcast but some of the
writing will notice that one of the
questions I like to ask oftentimes is
some variation of the following in the
last five years what have you become
better at saying no to such as
distractions invitations and so on
what new realizations and/or approaches
have helped you may note that what's
fantastic about this question is that
it's hard to avoid answering this is
true even if actually especially if
someone refuses
answer so when I asked Wendy if she'd
participate in this book she sent a very
thoughtful and perfect I have to pass
response after much consideration that
was in fact an answer to the question in
a sense I loved it so much that I said
here's perhaps a very odd question might
you be okay with me printing this very
polite decline email in the book to
which she agreed so here is the email
she sent me to decline being in trying
to mentor us which ended up in term of
mentors and now on the podcast just do
double duty so here we go and this is
very very very Wendy so you don't have
to sacrifice your personality or be cold
the impersonal to say no and a lot of
this can serve as a template and help
you to determine how you can establish
perhaps set language for declining here
we go hi Tim gah okay I've been battling
with this and here's the deal after five
intense years of creative output and
promotion interviews about personal
journeys and where ideas come from
after years of wrapping up one project
one day and jumping right into promoting
another to the next dot-dot-dot
I'm taking a step back I recently maxed
out pretty hard and for the benefit of
my work I got to take a break over the
past month I've cancelled contracts and
said no to new projects and interviews
I've started creating more space to
explore and doodle again to sit and do
nothing to wander and waste a day and
for the first time in five years I'm
finally in a place where there's no due
date tied to every drawing no deadline
for ideas and it feels really right so
while I really want to do this with you
I respect you and your work and I'm
honored that you'd ask me to participate
and its capital s stupid as it is for me
professionally not to do it I'm going to
have to say thank you but dot dot I got
a pass I'm simply not in a place talk
about myself or my work right now crazy
for a highly verbal only child to say
hopefully we will get a chance to talk
somewhere down the line I promise any
thoughts I'll have for you then it will
be far more insightful than anything I
could share with you right now
I hope the space created by my absence
is filled by one of the brilliant people
I suggested in my
is email which in fact ended up being
the cases is Tim talking several of them
are in try both mentors and really thank
you so much for your interest I'll be
kicking myself when the book comes out
Wendy so that's number one
the next rejection letter has a
different feel to it but is nonetheless
very very effective and it is from Danny
Meyer who is Danny Meyer well you can
see him on Twitter at D H Mayer m ey ER
or at us h g NYC calm and you'll learn
what that stands for just momentarily
Danny Meyer is the founder and CEO of
Union Square Hospitality Group that's
the u.s. Hg of the u.s. Hg NYC dot-com
which comprises some of New York's most
beloved and acclaimed restaurants
including Gramercy Tavern the modern
maialino and more Danny and USA she
founded Shake Shack the modern day
roadside burger restaurant which became
a public company in 2015 Danny's book
setting the table subtitle the
transforming power of hospitality in
business in New York Times best seller
articulates a set of signature business
and life principles that translate to a
wide range of industries Danny was
included and in 2015 Time magazine 100
most influential people list all right
so for your reading pleasure or
listening pleasure in this case and to
scratch your schadenfreude ah each
here's another polite decline email this
one from famed restaurant or Danny Meyer
now he sent this email to a friend of
mine Jeffery who asked on my behalf so
he was rejecting me but using Jeffery as
a go-between because Jeffery is a good
friend to both of us wanted to protect
contact information on either side until
then he said yes please connect us would
love to chat that ended up not being the
case so here is the email that Danny
sent and these are all published with
permission Jeffery comma greetings and
thanks for writing I'm grateful for the
invitation to participate in Tim's next
book prod
but I'm struggling at this moment to
make time ends meet for all we're doing
at US hg including my ongoing
procrastination with my own writing
projects i thought carefully about this
that's a very important line i thought
carefully about this as it's clearly a
wonderful opportunity but i'm going to
decline with gratitude no the book will
be a big success exclamation point
thanks again Danny and there are
different variations of that closing
line and you'll notice in both cases it
was in effect I'm sure the book or I
know the book will be a big success I'll
be kicking myself when it comes out in
this case no the book will be a big
success I've heard other variations and
received other variations such as I'll
be cheering from the sidelines I wish I
could be part of it and the sentiment in
these is very important if you want to
have the effect these people had on me
which is they decline they refuse my
invitation very politely and I actually
respect them and admire them more after
the rejection than before there is a
craft to this then you can borrow a lot
of this language alright the last one
that I'm going to read is from one of my
favorite writers of all time and he is a
contemporary shouldn't say he's a
contemporary of mine that makes it seem
like I'm in the same league which I am
certainly not but he is an iconic
science fiction writer Neil Stevenson in
e-a-l
as teph en esto n on Twitter at Neil
Stevenson Facebook is the Neil Stevenson
and you can learn more about him at Neil
Stevenson comm one of the most
fascinating human beings I have ever
encountered and I've had the good
fortune of meeting Neil then and again
in Seattle through my friend Chris young
scientist and incredible writer himself
at chefsteps
and beyond but back to Neil Neil
Stevenson is an author known for his
speculative fiction works variously
categorized as science fiction
historical fiction maximalism and
cyberpunk his bestsellers include among
others the die
in age krypton nomicon the Baroque cycle
and Snow Crash which was named one of
Time Magazine's top 100 all-time best
english-language novels that's a hell of
a thing Neil also writes nonfiction
articles about technology and
publications such as Wired magazine and
has worked part-time as an advisor for
Blue Origin a company developing a
manned sub orbital launch system and
going off script here a little bit just
to add color
Neil is one of those people who will
reach out to astrophysicists and
mechanical engineers and so on to
interview them dig into the details and
text books related to say rocket design
just get a few paragraphs in one of his
books technically correct to such an
extent that then people were on the
cutting edge we'll go back to his book
just to refer to what the future might
hold it's that good and he does this in
many many many many many different
domains it's it's pretty mind-boggling
ok so by now you know what I'm about to
read you this is the type of email that
makes me cry and smile at the same time
so here with a lovely hasta la próxima
until next time from one of my idols
writer neal stephenson here we go hey
there Tim sorry for the slow response
and thanks for thinking of me in this
context it has become pretty obvious of
late that I'm trying to do too much and
so I started an experiment of not adding
anything whatsoever to my to-do list so
that it wouldn't get any longer the
result is that the items that were
already on my to-do list only spawned
more items as I cross them off and so
it's a little like fighting a Hydra it's
the most neill thing to say ever all
right so it's a little like fighting a
Hydra I am hoping that if I am
ruthlessly efficient I can one day get
to the point where the list actually
gets shorter instead of longer in the
meantime
unfortunately the ruthlessly efficient
part of this plan means that I'm turning
down things like this just as a blanket
policy again thanks for thinking of me
and good luck with the project
exclamation point
all right there are few commonalities I
want to highlight here and that I've
certainly translated into my own
language and a lot of the declines that
I send out and I have to and you have to
for that matter if you have any modicum
of success even a toehold and something
that might be a success
your default answer to almost everything
should be no and this is a pattern that
comes up over and over and over again in
tribe mentors both in this podcast and
also in the book itself when I ask
people how do you say no what are the
tips tactics and strategies and so on
there are a few commonalities number one
is explaining the predicament that you
are in and you don't have to go along
with it but simply saying my own to-do
list in this case is spawning more and
more items and getting longer instead of
shorter and there you have it you can
keep it short and to the point but in in
a sense you're explaining the context
and then the second word that I'd like
to highlight in Neil's is policy so it's
not personal it's not that I'm saying no
to your idea it's not that I think
you're a terrible person but in fact I
am as I've been turned down before by in
one case a billionaire investor who I
actually met before he said I would love
to meet but unfortunately I am I'm
following a no meeting policy for the
next quarter I'm not meeting with anyone
as a policy right alright so it makes it
a blanket response and I know that I
along with many others are getting
rejected another way I've heard this
phrased is I'm going on and across the
board for instance Coffee no coffee diet
or no conference call diet for the next
month for the next quarter for the next
year whatever it might be that is a
rejection format that I received when I
invited someone to speak at a conference
for instance I'm going on an O
conference diet for the next year
because last year I realized that I over
committed to so much and by over
calendaring ultimately the things that
most excited me had in a room to fit
into my life etc right so those are a
few examples of how to say no
in such a way that is perfectly clear
you're not saying pay me in three months
and we'll see what happens it's very
clear that the answer is no but
hopefully if it's delivered well that
people will respect you more they might
not like it they might be upset but they
will respect you and then over time
typically the wounds heal if there are
any and they realize that you did
exactly the right thing and then they
may even borrow the language that you
sent them and I should highlight also
this isn't a panacea it's just a better
tool in the at the end of the day you
cannot control how people respond to the
decisions you make but as I think it's
Herbert Swope who was a Nobel Prize
recipient has said there is no one path
to success but I can give you the recipe
for failure and that is trying to please
everyone all of the time that's a
paraphrase but you get the point all
right guys thank you for listening to
this short episode I hope you enjoyed it
I certainly have found a way to enjoy
getting rejection letters which makes me
happy and if you'd like to learn more
about how to say no dozens of different
approaches dozens of different
techniques from people ranging from
Dustin Moskovitz co-founder of Facebook
to everybody imaginable check out tribe
of mentors the book there 130 plus
people profiled I asked them all this
question and you can check it out at
tribe of mentors calm or find it on
being calm Amazon any bookseller
anywhere at bookstores all over the
place that is it for now so until next
time thank you for listening this
episode is brought to you by convertkit
my go-to email service provider a lot of
you have asked me what I use for email
and I've been hesitant to tell you
because I don't want to give them the
hug of death and have my own service
drop so after much consideration I
finally said yes to convertkit being a
sponsor email is a huge priority for me
and I trust convertkit as my
Espie my email service provider it's the
only platform that I can completely
control and customize and I need a
service that ensures the right
information is sent to my followers and
listeners and I cannot afford downtime a
very little patience work so tried all
sorts of different platforms and
ultimately selected convertkit because
they deliver on what matters most to me
and my team easy-to-use systems
split testing super important and
resending technology say - on opens high
rates of deliverability and excellent
customer service when I needed something
from them when my team has needed
something from them they've always been
that so whether you run a business or
just have a professional blog let's say
convertkit offers email automation which
allows you to send well-timed targeted
content to your audience or your
customers the platform has all sorts of
integrations with more than 35 services
including say hosting sites such as
WordPress and commerce platforms like
Shopify lead capture technology like the
balanced exchange sumo and many many
more they offer plans that can adjust to
meet the size of your business and they
can scale with you
so convertkit can handle you whether you
have a thousand people or 1 million
people on your email list let's take a
look
convert kit compote / Tim that's Co nd
er T ki t compote / Tim and you can get
your first month for free that way you
can test the platform kick the tires
make sure that it works for you and your
business and if you're like me hopefully
fingers crossed because I only like to
recommend things that scale and do
really well for everybody
I hope that you find they get the job
done that's certainly been the case for
me again that is convertkit com forward
slash Tim for a free month of email
services check it out
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for many many
years now travels with me on my
smartphone in my pocket at all times
I love audiobooks and they are one of my
favorite ways to make the most of the
time or just past the time when I'm
taking walks cooking or on the road in
airplanes and so audible has allowed me
to consume and enjoy many many more
books than I would have otherwise been
able to you can access an unbeatable
selection of bestsellers biographies
mysteries thrillers fantasy sci-fi few
nerds like me and much more so I can
recommend a few right off the bat ready
player one by Ernest Cline if you want
your sci-fi fix very very good stuff the
Tao of Seneca by Seneca wants you here
my favorite letters of all time than
that is one option I have to add one
more perhaps my favorite narration ever
the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the
version read by Neil himself okay as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show as well
you can join audible for just 495 per
month that's four dollars and 95 cents
per month for your first three months
it's regularly 1495 so you saved quite a
bunch this offer is available to new
audible members only and it ends
December 31st 2017 go to audible.com
forward slash Tim that's audible.com
forward slash Tim or text Tim T I am to
five hundred five hundred to get started
now I wasn't sure what that meant so I
tried it out it's pretty cool technology
actually you just text TI m to five zero
zero five zero zero as the phone number
then it delivers the URL and page
directly to it's pretty cool I actually
might play around with that so you can't
make more time but you can make the most
of it check it out audible.com forward
slash Tim four text the word Tim
lowercase T I am to five hundred five
hundred to check it out and get started
now
you